um hi everyone it's so cool that you're
here feels like it's been a very long
time since the last like in person
conference so this is really nice it's a
bit new again
if it wasn't obvious from the awkward
hand waving from the corner amyan and
this is this is christian
and yes we are both
data science slash data engineers at
quantco
you might be a bit confused because the
title of this presentation has changed
slightly however semantically it has
stayed the same we're going to talk
about decoupling model training from
inference using onyx
maybe with regards to
a bit of a glossary here what do we mean
by inference
inference is a word that we use quite
heavily maybe excessively we basically
mean making predictions so if we we also
try to stick to the word prediction if
you catch us here the word inference
that's what we mean
okay so why is decoupling model training
from inference so important or why do we
think it's so important
well
i probably got to point you there yes
well i've recently looked up some
some from some survey that 55 of
companies who have started with machine
learning have failed to put their models
into production
and this number is from 2020 i doubt
this has changed much since then
and i mean this is a pretty big number
right 55 percent and even though there
might be many
benefits to having machine learning for
maybe exploratory reasons or
other purposes
i still argue that being able to maybe
enhance the business process or automate
something by putting a model into
production is where the majority of the
value lies so if you fail at doing that
then maybe you you're missing out on the
majority of the cool stuff you could do
and um
well considering that so many companies
failed it like deploying models seems to
be more complicated than it might look
at for first glance
so this is basically what we want to
convey
today
we want to show you
why it is so difficult to put machine
learning models into production
and how onyx as a universal file format
for machine learning models can help you
overcome this challenge
and at the end we want to convey a bit
this idea of thinking in onyx and how
you can convert your own models into
this specification
and with that being said i would pass it
over to my colleague christian who could
maybe tell us why this is so darn
difficult
yes thank you very much and also
hello and thank you for coming from my
side
as jan just mentioned it seems that
sometimes
the deployment just seems to be harder
than initially thought and in the
following we just want to walk you
through the process how a machine
learning project
probably quite often actually starts out
and then sort of develops and then sort
of
collides
with the requirements
of deployment
you gotta point to here
okay so
your common projects given that you're
at a python conference i would be uh not
surprised to learn that some of these
projects here to the left-hand side are
somewhat familiar to you this is
probably the toolset you would be using
to
start with your machine learning
projects to do the data exploration then
to build your first model to
yeah just
essentially build your model now why
would you do that like what do we
appreciate about these models they
really give like this fast iteration
uh
debugging data exploration we can then
sort of visualize our current results
and then go back change everything okay
so we would do that uh
using these tools maybe for a few months
then we finally have like a nice complex
model
that performs nicely gives us good good
results as we expect and then well i
suppose it's time
to move our model that we just build
using these tools into
production
i'm just going to use the button
and well now sort of it's the time to
look up well how would we how would we
do that we go to the scikit-learn
documentation
uh we look at chapter nine model
persistence
uh
and we find okay well there are not a
lot of options we take the very first
option that is
presented to us in the officials i could
learn documentation and it just says
well
pickle your model lack of options i
suppose so that's exactly what we're
going to do
we pickle it we ship it
done deployment is actually easy
thanks for coming
[Laughter]
well
let's see how this
devolves in in the deployment and the
way we are going to do this now uh i'm
going to be the the data scientist to
some extent who just built the model and
jan is going to be the data engineer who
actually then sort of tries to put it
into production with a with a web
service and we're just gonna
do a bit of uh play back and forth so i
just pick up the model
and now i hand it over to yarn yes
exactly so i received the model i don't
know how sophisticated your model
exchange process is it might be
something like passing it over slack or
i don't know you'll find a way to get
the model to me and so i i get this file
i'm like okay what's this pickle and
basically what i'm trying to do at first
is to
build a rest api around it maybe use
fast api use flask make it available to
to our like external microservices
and so i basically unpickle the the the
thing and that's the first thing i get
module not found no module and sklearn
i'm like what does that mean
what is going on right and this is the
very first thing that some of you might
be aware of but maybe not all of you
pickles are not fully self-contained in
fact to unpickle something you basically
need the exact same packages that you
used during training to reuse your
your pickled python object
and there's a myriad of terrible
terrible consequences with that and
we're not going into depth with like
security concerns and all these funny
things you can do when i'm pickling
something there's funny talks out there
already about this topic but basically
it means
like now i'm saying well christian i
can't unpickle this like what am i
supposed to do now well uh
probably you gonna look up the
documentation on pickle as you just said
you will learn you have to just
reproduce essentially the environment or
at least like all the dependencies that
are mentioned in the pickle in your
deployment so in this case we certainly
probably want to have pandas
and scikit-learn as our dependencies
depending maybe we use some custom
classes with like some plotting
functionality maybe we need even more
like mud plot lip etc so what we
probably would do is we just take our
training environment
and uh
completely put it into our production
environment with all the dependencies
and there you go you can load your
pickle yeah like again how hard can it
be that's when i start rolling my eyes
and i start installing all these
dependencies that i suddenly need for
unloading this pickle and yeah
admittedly it works i need to be very
careful to have the very same versions
installed and all these things but yeah
i can make it work and i put it into i
put it into the rest api i put it in
production and i let it run i do my my
benchmarks to make sure it's performant
and then next roadblock
the model is too slow
because maybe i have a specific use case
where um i send single row like requests
to my model rather than batches and i
want them to be very snappy and very
responsive and suddenly i have this
major sklearn pipeline which takes
hundreds of milliseconds to make a
single single response and i'm like
i can't put this in production into
production in a micro service it's too
slow and i start looking into
christian's code and i see a bunch of
for loops and i'm like what are you
doing there like you got to make this
more performant man and so basically say
you got to do something about this and i
pass it back to him well and i do of
course what everybody in this situation
would do i replace the for loops i
essentially go back to the model i
change the model i sprinkle some numpy
magic on top of it where it's uh where
it's benefits maybe even some number
and yeah there you go it got faster your
latency went down
uh
yeah
oh no nice that was possibly the wrong
button there we go here you go so uh
again we're good uh we can put it into
production
finally exactly i think at this point
we're like two weeks in at least uh but
finally we got it to work and it's been
it's been running for a while quite
successfully
but then like um suddenly you know a
couple of couple weeks or months later i
get this this email from from business
and they have this fantastic idea of why
don't we use the model directly from
java
and i'm like what
like like how like how are we supposed
to do this this this is a python object
like what am i supposed to do now um and
i also just look at christian like
if you have any idea like what i should
do now well in this case i suppose we
are somewhat out of ideas yeah uh
implemented or like what are we supposed
to do exactly of course we could just
say well i guess we have to like
re-implement everything and then a
framework that sort of would be more
amendable to be used directly from java
instead of essentially interfacing with
python
or we take a step back and we look a
little
why
did this deployment actually turn out to
be so difficult what if what if we could
just use the tools we really like for
that exploration for
training of the model and then
we have this universal file format
where we essentially export our model to
and then from this universal file format
we are then free to choose whatever
runtime we want to use in production it
doesn't need to be cycle we can use
scikit-learn here on the left hand side
and
then we just use this universal file
that we exported to and we load it into
a runtime with nice java bindings and
good performance now
again
or what would that give us to sort of
like really put it into like explicit
words what we want to do is we want to
really decouple our training from our
prediction time so we want to use the
tools for training we want to use then
export it to something universal and
then be completely
free in our tools we want to use for for
deployment now again uh
if this were a pie in the sky we would
probably be not holding this talk right
now so
fortunately
there is already quite an ecosystem ah i
keep hitting the wrong button i'm sorry
there is already an ecosystem there is
this universal file format it is called
onyx uh
we go more into detail there later and
then on the prediction side there are
these interpreters or runtimes that take
this universal file format and
essentially interpret your model
so for example the the reference one is
is called onyx runtimes here on the
right hand side on the very top
it's a c plus library with nice bindings
and all sorts of languages but there are
also other runtimes that are more geared
towards embedded devices for example a
pi zero or you could even do crazy stuff
like take your model and completely
compile it down into machine code here
with the with the uh last project on the
right hand side and then of course
not explicitly mentioned here on the
slide but if you want to go from your
trained model
to the onyx format so uh the
left hand side of the hourglass you also
need converters that take your
scikit-learn model and then sort of put
it into the file format we're going to
talk about that later but also those
already exist now onyx
what is it how does it work
let's go to their homepage and
take a look
and we are greeted by a name that
frankly
might not sound so encouraging depending
on what kind of models you are building
because onyx is the aberration for
open neural network exchange
and
before you sort of then close your tab
in disappointment because you're like oh
no i'm actually
not using deep neural networks
i'm
using linear regressions or tree models
or whatever
rest assure this is just
not the best name for the project
because this is really
generic for all kinds of machine
learning
so it is not limited to to neural
networks
now what it is to like re-emphasize it's
the standardized way to
[Music]
describe your entire model including
your feature engineering and to store it
into a binary format that is
in essence
what it really is
and
around this
specification uh that is now a few years
old actually we have a growing ecosystem
of converters from scikit-learn to this
file format and runtimes that
essentially then interpret your model
with whatever properties are best for
your deployment
and well
uh also nice benefits uh are it's
with a liberal license so you will not
have a problem actually using it in your
deployment and it really does have a
good corporate backing in this case like
the onyx specification and also the onyx
runtime that i mentioned on the previous
slide are actually both developed by
microsoft so it's not like some hobby
project or something
okay so
onyx this is all very theoretical let's
look a little closer how
does onyx
achieve all these
promises
okay so
this is really the the one of the most
important points to take away from this
talk
onyx
you need to be able to describe your
model or you need to think about your
model
as a computational graph namely as a
directed a circle graph so without loops
if you can sort of put the logic of your
machine learning model into this sort of
computational flow where you put the
input in at the top
and then it goes to an operator like in
this example for example the add
operator and then the result from that
goes to the next operator in this case a
linear regressor and then you get the
output back if you can put your model
into this kind of format
then it works for onex and this is
exactly how onyx describes your model
okay
so
the nodes
as i
just said actually are operators there's
a whole set i'm going to mention that in
a moment and the edges they are actually
the data flowing through your graph um
important side note uh onyx is strongly
typed so all the edges actually have
type information like be it flowed into
jira strings and actually
also shape but that's not so important
for our case here okay so this is all
nice and well
what does onyx specifically say so onyx
defines us
a set of operators so you can't just
willy nilly make your own
operator named xyz and think it works
now of course it has to be like in the
set of specified operators at the time
of making this talk there are actually
175 operators out there so
it's not only like easy stuff like add
it's really also like more involved ones
like linear regressor or
true ensemble regressors etc
so
onyx defines these
operators and then also like this
uh
stuff you need around it to actually
then sort of put all the operators into
a graph and to store the data associated
with each operator so
add might not have data associated with
it but the linear regressor of course
has been trained on your data so you
need to store those coefficients
somewhere and onyx defines that so that
everything is self-sufficient contrary
to the pickle before the onyx
file you get at the end is really
completely self-contained no no other
dependencies needed for
for reading it in okay
so let's take a closer look at what for
example the specification for one of
these operators might look like just
just one example of these 175
operators
that is not too complicated and not too
trivial so i chose the binarizer you
might be familiar it's essentially an
operation where you get an input value
if it's above a certain threshold you
set it to one or the output is one if
it's below a threshold the output is
zero so obviously for this operator you
need to store the threshold so the onyx
standard specifies okay for the operator
binarizer you need to store a floating
point value
with a threshold where you make the
split and then this operator gets
exactly one input array of type t
and produces exactly one output array of
the same type as the input and in
general
this operator is then sort of
implemented or should be implemented by
the runtime for
the following types at the bottom namely
what you would expect i suppose floating
points and integers
okay and then for all 175 operators
there are like these kind of definitions
of what it what it expects as input
output and
what attributes can be stored with it
okay
all nice and well
very theoretical
what you know at this point is
there is some format that claims
to be able to store your machine
learning model
in a in a generic
format and that can be read by other
stuff
well okay
again theoretical
now jan is gonna tell you a little more
put a little me to the bone and tell you
more of how you can actually convert
your existing model
into this uh onyx format yes i will try
to so
this is probably a point we will keep on
repeating over and over and over again
but in order to convert whatever you
have to onyx it needs to be
representable as a directed acyclic
graph that only uses operations
specified in the onyx framework
and
point there we go
in fact and that's also something we
want to stress because many people like
don't really realize that
it's not really limited to only
converting your estimator which is
possibly only the very last step in your
pipeline you can convert your entire
pipeline and as like there's nothing
that limits you from doing that in fact
i would go as far as saying you can
convert
almost arbitrary code to onyx
assuming you can represent it as a
directed acyclic graph it doesn't need
to have to do anything with machine
learning if you think about it could be
any algorithm it could be anything that
follows a certain ast
the only thing is that
shouldn't have any loops etc shouldn't
shouldn't should be
representable as a directed acyclic
graph
and coincidentally well machining
pipelines in essence are directed
acyclic graphs um if we think about this
toy example of a pipeline with four
steps you can see well they have arrows
there's always a good point like for
them being directed there's no like
arrows going back to the beginning so
that means they're not acyclic and this
is technically a very simple example of
a directed acyclic graph however
to be compatible with onyx we also need
to be able to represent each and every
step in this pipeline as a directed
acyclic graph so basically what is now a
node in our graph on the sort of
abstract circuit learn level will turn
into a graph itself in the onyx level
and what i mean with that is for example
if we look at the simple imputer on the
left hand side
and we assume it has a very very simple
implementation where it's just a bunch
of numpy operations we first create a
mask so we find the missing values
we store that information and then we
replace the missing values with a
defined impute value and for all other
values we just pass on the original
values so it's a very simple numpy
operation which can very easily be
defined as a graph of onyx operators
which would look basically like this
so basically on the scikit-learn level
we would have a simple imputer when we
convert it it's going to be a graph of
an input an impute value and is none
operation a where operation and a
defined output
and to give you one more example to
really like make that sink in
we could do the same for the regressor
like i mean a regressor is not a black
box right we know how it works it's
essentially a matrix multiplication of
coefficients and inputs and an addition
of the of the intercept and essentially
usually all that you really need to look
at
is how is the transform or the predict
method of the corresponding class
implemented because that shows you what
is the actual underlying algebra the
mathematical formulation of this this
step that you need to express
so i think this gives you a good idea of
basically how replace how by replacing
every node in this scikit-learn graph by
a graph itself we convert scikit-learn
into an onix format
yes
and so now the question is is this lots
of work and well it depends as always
if you
only choose to stick with established
machine learning frameworks psychic
learn pytorch tensorflow light gbm xg
boost chances are
somebody has written these converters
for you
like maybe that's also a strong point to
emphasize as opposed to something like
number where they basically inspect the
source code and compile things on the
fly there's no such thing for onyx you
at some point have to manually say well
the representation of the inference
logic or the prediction logic of this
class maps to this graph and somebody
has to do the hard work and again as
this is very well maintained by
lots of bigger tech corporates
many of these um conversion functions
this conversion logic it already exists
and you can just use it and be done with
it
if you happen to have custom estimators
custom transformers in in your at your
company you will need to write your own
converters and this can be
painful or it can be relatively easy the
learning curve is a bit steep but you
can you can make it work it is
technically feasible assuming it fits
into a deck
that is i think also a very very
important takeaway here
and
this is basically these are all the
libraries that
you will probably be able to use almost
out of the box because converters have
already been written
namely there's things like onyx ml tools
or skl to onyx that can convert these
these libraries
i think it covers pretty much everything
all right
on to the live demo
what could possibly
go wrong
i think the first thing we got to figure
out is how to zoom in i remember this
was a bit of an issue
at yesterday's lightning talks but this
was a lot easier than back then if
anybody was there
so like we're basically um
the the thing that we did in this very
amateur theatrical play earlier on stage
we're now doing in code right like right
now we're in the training phase it's the
data scientist building their model
they're importing a bunch of stuff from
scikit-learn
just that you see this is a fairly
fairly recent psychic-learned version
i'm just doing some config stuff that is
not particularly relevant making sure
that my tests don't fail so i rather set
a a random seed
and now here i'm producing some
artificial
test input and an artificial test output
so the input for our pipeline that you
will see in a second is basically an
array with floating point values between
5 and 10.
some of them being non-value so we have
a couple of empty ones
and our target
variable is also just a
bunch of floating point numbers
essentially
and um
we can create a pipeline like this um i
think you should mostly be aware of that
like how to create pipelines in psychic
learn um
we can visualize it this might look
familiar this might look very similar to
what we just had on the on the slides
and
i'm going to go ahead as a good data
scientist i'm going to fit this on the
entire data set as you're supposed to
which usually gives great
training accuracy
and uh yeah at this point i'm pretty
much done with my workflow right i've
trained a model i'm happy um and now i
want to make this available to the data
engineer so i'm going ahead and using
the existing conversion libraries and as
we said in the case of scikit-learn to
onyx it's it's quite simple we import a
simple function called in convert
sklearn we also have to import a bunch
of
different data types why is that the
case well
the
since
onyx is strongly typed it needs
the initial information of what you pass
on to it or into what you provide to it
and then the the subsequent types can be
inferred from the operations but the
initial types need to be provided
now you can infer the the types very
easily if you for example have a pandas
data frame you can write a very simple
mapping of the pandas data types to the
onyx data types this is what we do
internally at quantco but for the sake
of simplicity we just basically hard
code that the initial types for this
onyx graph are going to be a
float tensor type with
10 columns in arbitrary many rows
and then we pass all this information on
to the conversion function
and goes through very quickly and we
suddenly have an onyx model
and the onyx model it defines a bunch of
metadata that we will not go into depth
but the most relevant part is what you
see here as graph
you can see it defines a couple of nodes
here we can see this is um an operator
of type imputer
it defines a couple of attributes as we
saw earlier a couple like different
other nodes whole bunch of stuff is in
here
and this is a fully self-contained
mathematical
extraction of the prediction logic of
your pipeline that has no
remaining
touch points to the original circuit
learned model
so this is basically where the data
science
responsibility stops all you now have to
do is basically dump this into a file
and again make this available to the
data engineer
everything that happens from this point
onwards could technically happen in a
completely different environment with
different dependencies
on a different day in a different year
by a different person but for the sake
of the simplicity this happens in the
same notebook but again we completely
decouple things
so now as a data engineer i'm quite
happy because the only actual
library the only actual dependency that
i have is the onyx runtime and that is
consistent regardless of what kind of
model i have been serializing before so
no matter whether the model came from
tensorflow python circuit learn my only
dependency that i have here is the onyx
runtime
so i import this inference session class
and i instantiate it by basically
passing on
a file path to a model file
and then again the api is not
fantastic but it gets the job done you
can write a very simple abstraction
around it you basically run this session
object you say what kind of
output from the graph like every every
node has an id so that's the id of the
output that you want to get the data
from
and then you provide the the inputs as
basically
a mapping of the input id to the data
that it should be passed on to
then you need to do a bit of reshaping
because again api is not great but i'm
sure you could figure that out on your
own
and then to prove that we're not lying
and that the predictions are actually
the same up to six decimal places
drum roll
nice
so
scikit-learn and onyx produce the same
predictions to a to us satisfying
accuracy or precision if you're curious
why these predictions are not exactly
the same we can maybe talk about this
after the actual content of this
presentation and just go a bit into like
the nitty gritties but in the majority
of use cases big accurate successful
place that should should get you most of
the way
another thing that we complained about
at the beginning was
inference speed so prediction speed so
we set up a very simple benchmark
the first thing that we're going to
benchmark is the prediction time on the
overall batch
and if i remember correctly the input
data had 1000 rows
so with scikit-learn let's see how this
is how long this is going to take
500 microseconds per loop in average
and now let's check with um with onyx
and again here we're using the default
onyx runtime which is written in c plus
and provides python bindings
and
we're down to 30 microseconds so that's
quite nice that's factor 10
on something that was already very
simple and optimized to begin with
because we didn't use anything fancy in
the original pipeline it was just a
linear regression and an imputer
essentially
and what was also very very relevant for
us especially in the in the case where
you put models into an online
environment and you want to make
predictions in real time we personally
really care about single row prediction
speed
and i just want to confirm that we're
basically getting similar results here
again first for the second second learn
case
and you can see that
in just a second
this still takes about 170 milliseconds
microseconds on a single row
and with onyx we will go down quite a
bit
to
about seven microseconds
so and to tell you a bit like you know
like a little story from our production
use case we actually managed to go down
like a hundred times like two orders of
magnitude rather than just one because
just the
in-going secular object was so much more
complex than what we've just described
all right then i would say this have we
have seen
onto the summary with christian thank
you
all right so
the premise of the talk was uh
to like demonstrate to you that
oftentimes we start off a project we use
the tools we like for the very good
reasons
because at the very beginning of our
machine learning project we want this
fast iteration and
visualization and everything that we get
sort of from the sort of default python
tools but then if we follow the standard
practice even in the scikit-learn
documentation we essentially really end
up coupling our training environment to
our deployment environment and we really
lose
many many options of what we could then
finally do with our model in deployment
now
if you use onyx
uh you can decouple the two you can
continue using scikit-learn then you
export it to this universal file format
and then you use something like the
honest grunt time or some other runtime
to essentially read in your onyx
graph and to interpret it
with whatever performance
characteristics you actually need for
your real deployment
then of course there's the universal law
of no free lunch
which means
somehow you need to get your cycle learn
or whatever model
into this universal format now as we've
also as you've just seen in the live
demo
whether that's like
almost no work or can get pretty
involved kind of depends on exactly the
nature of your project if you stick to
the standard framework you should be
pretty fine if it's a little more custom
always think in graphs can you map your
model into this direct
directed asymptotic graph with like
these onyx nodes as like the
common denominator then you should be
fine it might still be a little bit of
work but you should be fine
if your model does some really funky
stuff then
it might not be a perfect fit but um to
be evaluated then and yeah so in any
case we can really recommend looking
into onyx
for like many many reasons uh not only
performance but also like archiving it
etc so it's it is a really it is a
technology we are actually very excited
about and
well if you find yourself to also be
excited about work like this maybe uh
look into quantco
and uh yeah that's it from our side
thank you thank you
[Music]
so we can move on to the q and a session
if you haven't you still have the
opportunity to vote for your favorite
questions
and we have plenty of time left
as intended to ask the really tough
questions
because there seem to be quite a few
skeptics in the audience let's say all
right bring it on
that's why the most uploaded question
currently is why not just throw
everything into a docker container solve
the dependency hell and it scales nicely
well uh
there was the premise at the very end
wasn't it and it scales nicely uh so i
well let's take a step back i think
there are like several things like if
you throw it into a docker container and
you want to use the same model for
example in two years time but maybe in a
slightly different environment then well
it doesn't work so much anymore then you
would need to use your old docker
container and call into it from your new
environment and
not so nice anymore and also
the scaling part is not really a given
it might very well be that your
scikit-learn is not going to perform
good enough for your use case or that
something changes and suddenly you can't
use your python environment anymore and
then if you sort of stick
with like essentially just pickle it put
it in a docker that essentially still
couples like you have to use those tools
that you use because they're like nice
and interactive and fast to iterate for
your training you still have to use them
in deployment and that really is not
necessarily what you want
so
yeah i'm not saying that
it doesn't work with putting it into
docker but there are many things that
might sort of just not work out so well
or it would just be nice to have more
flexibility in how exactly you deploy it
also in our example of course if you for
example want to train your model and
then use it on an android application
from java that's not going to work so
well with a docker container but it
would still be nice to actually be able
to use scikit-learn maybe like two more
things as an addition but i totally
agree with what christian said so one
thing is that for example
the decoupling is a really really
important part and for example this
albeit maybe rather
exotic use case where suddenly you want
to have this running natively inside of
an android application or of a java
desktop software you don't solve these
things through docker the only thing you
can actually do with docker is basically
provide a
rest api so basically the sort of the
the happy path the
the use case that maybe is most relevant
to you as a as a company
um
but yeah the other thing is that with
docker since you add so many other
layers around it like the the the the
the archive or the artifact that you
produce
it's not really just your model it's all
these other things as well
and um by serializing it to onyx and
then putting it for example on disk you
have this this this pure essence of just
your your mathematical formulation of
your model that you can always load back
in and see oh yeah this is somewhat
human readable i can totally see what's
happening here that you don't have that
with putting it into a docker image
thank you very much um i'm gonna sneak
in one question i just saw
are you gonna share the notebook or is
this available somewhere we can share it
we can totally share it but it's not
available yet
okay um
[Music]
you figure this out yes i don't know i'm
gonna
text you all on whatsapp i don't know
uh next question what are the cons of
onix and when should you avoid using it
what does
there have to have to be some downsides
how much time do you have left
um about eight minutes okay cool
you want to start well uh yeah okay
um
yes again no free lunch and also it's
not like the perfect solution for every
use case no doubt about it
again if you use of the established
things
a lot of the converters already work and
you get a lot of the nice stuff from
onyx almost for free
then if it's sort of
you have to you used your you created
your own
classes that maybe inherit from some
psychic learn operators and do some some
extra stuff you would need to write your
own converters might might be a bit of
work but probably works
where you should really
reconsider if it's like the best fit is
if you
would
if you for example need a lot of
recursion in your model or if you would
need to do some funky stuff depending
like you execute halfway through your
model and then maybe you have to fetch
some resources do some i o or whatever
depending on sort of some state in the
middle of your product uh prediction i
would add one more thing to that because
the thing with the conversion right
writing your own converters we have a
pretty big internal library with like a
whole bunch of custom estimators and
transformers and i think writing all the
converters was like four and a half
thousand lines of code so it was quite
involved and took us quite a lot of time
to get it right but now that it's
working it was an initial overhead and
everything else like from now on we sort
of get for free the second thing that i
really i mean it's not really an onyx
issue but it has no native support for
categoricals so if you have a lot of
like pandas conversions and you like
categorical encodings and stuff like
that
you need to be very creative on how to
represent that it's possible we made it
work but it wasn't fun
so i think these are the two biggest
issues especially the second you could
just solve by encoding everything into
an integer or something at the very
beginning of your pipeline
but yeah it's it's a bit tedious
actually i have one more thing to add
sorry for the back and forth but uh also
you should really be aware that this is
a fairly new technology and the
ecosystem is rather new so
if you for example convert your models
it might be that you get like a fairly
cryptic error message
and then you might have to dig in or
right look up some issues and whatever
it's just it is a new ecosystem it's not
that mature yet i mean it's developing
uh
and i think it's very promising and i'm
very excited about it obviously but yeah
expectation management it is young there
are some rough edges so if you
don't want to spend your time reading
through a github issue or a pull request
or whatever uh or fix something yourself
yeah yeah then
you you might very well encounter some
rough edges
uh moving on to something completely
different
gpu acceleration the question is
how easy is deployment on gpu slash
parallelization on several gpus
afterwards
you you you okay so uh the the reference
runtime onyx runtime
actually has
as far as i know i don't have first-hand
experience with it but i'm pretty sure
it has actually um
uh
it
has some gpu
tooling around it
so again i
know firsthand experience but the
technology is technically there and it's
built on top of cuda as far as i'm aware
so it should just work with with the
default runtime you can give it some
options when you actually set it up
whether it should be single threaded
multi-threaded gpu etc
so technically there i don't have
first-hand experience and then again the
specification itself itself is not
limited in that way right it's just you
need a runtime and anybody can write one
you probably don't want to write one
yourself but technically anybody can
write a runtime
okay next question this time about
encryption
is it possible to encrypt onyx models
for protecting trained models against
unintended use example reserve engineer
reverse engineering to infer the trained
model parameters um
actually well half of the question i'm
very excited that someone did ask it
because
so taking a step back if you for example
were to use proprietary con
tools in your training those are of
course because the dependencies are not
necessary for deployment uh
you can essentially keep them really
separated so when when intellectual
property is a concern in this regard
onyx can also solve your issue
can it be reverse engineered
yes and no
so in practice if you have a fairly
complex model
you
you can read the the the coefficients
out of the model and there is even like
nice visualization tooling that makes it
pretty easy to find the the coefficients
in your model but
in our production model i think we have
like 20 000 nodes and there is no you
know it doesn't preserve like oh this
used to be this operator and this used
to be that pipeline so
to some extent it
it's security by uh obfuscation i
suppose uh to some extent uh but
yeah at the end if you actually ship the
the
onyx file it is fairly easy to get the
weight now there are projects i did show
it here on
we did show it
here
on the bottom right
that actually takes your onyx file which
is this binary well-defined file where
you would get the way it's very easy and
you can really compile it down to
machine code
so if you want to obfuscate it further
of course that's still not encrypted
you could go that way and then really
ship a binary that can be executed
directly
thank you very much
somebody asks for a couple more examples
of models that can't be
converted to directed acycle like asic
liquid graphs wow that's a mouthful
i mean
for example like this is more like
pre-processing rather than actually
having an estimator but imagine you have
a pre-processing step where you do look
up against the database
this is something where you have io and
this is something you can't you would
need to put basically all the data in
your database as an instantiator inside
of your onyx graph that's the only way
and then it's baked into the graph right
like there's no no no outside
communication happening i think that is
another good example outside of this all
recursion thing that we've mentioned
or maybe if you have really funky python
code you do something like while
something something do this and this and
this and this
it might be possible to sort of unroll
this while loop and put it into
something that is more static as a graph
but maybe not always
as a caveat technically you could extend
the existing onyx specification
like not the specification itself but
you could create your own nodes that is
like then you are very deep on the ex
advanced side but nothing would stop you
for example to create uh
your own node that does
do this particular logic and then you
would need to link it essentially to the
onyx runtime but that would certainly be
a lot of work he really wants to write a
lure note i really want to do that
actually but
uh yeah but technically you could write
your own note that really does
completely arbitrary stuff but that
would be outside of the standardized
part you would lose a lot of likes of
the reusability
in this regard but technically possible
okay then one last question we have
about a minute left
um do i get a useful error when i put an
sk-learn pipeline into onyx which is not
supported
usability
so
we love skiller into onyx it does so
many great things but
meaningful error messages is not one of
them
so
sometimes you get really cryptic stuff
and we we had to fix quite a lot of
things upstream for especially for error
messages where we're like
again it's a kind of tooling where if
you like see a lot of red and you're
like well it doesn't work
then maybe you need to wait a couple
more years
or how do you see that question yeah
similar
a couple of years yeah maybe you're
right but i i i want to be more
optimistic actually i mean it is again
it's a young ecosystem but there is
actually quite a lot of movement in it
there is quite some corporate backing so
i hope that it really is going to
improve on a shorter time scale than two
years but currently again there are
rough edges so
if if a cryptic error message is uh
well they can be pretty scary i have to
admit it
yeah but uh yeah
then i would really like to thank you
for a very very interesting talk
and
yep
thank you